this is where the first person in
Germany confirmed with coronavirus was
infected it was at a company training
event here in the southern state of
Bavaria a week ago a Chinese colleague
attended it but after her return to
Shanghai she tested positive for the
virus
according to local health authorities a
German colleague then started showing
flu-like symptoms at the weekend a test
was carried out and yesterday evening
the results came back positive his
deepness
the patient is now being monitored in
hospital doctors say he is awake
responsive and without a fever
authorities have said further protective
measures have been put in place it's
given the focus now is on the people who
were in contact with the Chinese woman
and the people who had contact with the
infected German especially close health
officials say the man is in an isolation
room and is doing well and DW is
Emanuela chase is on the story she joins
us now with more
Emanuele what else was discussed at this
press conference well certainly the most
interesting information from that press
conference was to learn more but the way
the infection was spread one came from
Shanghai and she stayed only a couple of
days in Germany between the 19th and
23rd of January but her parents come
from Wuhan the affected region and they
visited her shortly before her German
stay and that's how the infection got to
Germany this woman didn't have any
symptoms and only on her way back from
Germany in the plane did she start to
feel sick and then she was checked by
the Sanitary of sanitary authorities
back in Shanghai where she was diagnosed
with a corona virus so that shows that
the transmission of the virus is
possible even during the incubation
phase before even any symptoms show and
one of the big concerns of course is how
to prevent this from spreading now what
efforts are underway well here in
Germany there are sanitary checks for
people coming from the affected areas in
China in five different airports that
the the biggest airport in Germany
Frankfurt also in Berlin Munich
Dusseldorf and Hamburg now the
authorities say they fairly prepared
even before the outbreak because they
were training they had simulations and
all measures have been reviewed before
the first case was detected and the
Foreign Affairs Ministry issued a travel
warning for German citizen and we're
still waiting for a decision whether or
not repatriate the nineteen German
nationals currently in Wuhan okay so I
mean that's the situation on the ground
right now in Bavaria how about the
country in general well so far health
officials don't think that for taking
measures such as wearing a face mask for
example are necessary but they won't
that even 15 minutes face to face with
someone infected could suffice to
contract the virus and now it's quite
difficult to differentiate the symptoms
of the corner virus to those from those
of a regular flu but like I said there
were preparations as preparations that
were ongoing even before the Chinese
outbreaks and they were reviewed before
even the first case was detected here in
Germany and all the people who were in
touch with the person in fact with the
woman who was infected have been
isolated we're talking about 40 people
currently under operate observation and
the man currently staying under
observation is not feeling particularly
here so so far the health authorities
say that with normal hygienic
precautions like washing hands or
regular airing of rooms this should be a
sufficient to prevent the spreading of
the virus Emanuele chase thank you thank
you now other than Germany more than a
dozen countries have confirmed cases of
the virus in China the death toll has
jumped to 100 with more than 4500 cases
confirmed scientific studies suggest
that each infected person passes the
virus on to two or three other people on
average entire cities are already under
quarantine and now the government has
asked people to delay foreign travel for
millions worrying and waiting are the
new normal well
spreading almost as rapidly as the
coronavirus itself is false information
about it t WS Peter Rolla Dahl joins us
now with more on that so I mean we have
these incorrect claims spreading on
social media what are they well we're
seeing a pattern that unfortunates
become all too familiar in situations
like these we're seeing you know false
and misleading information that's kind
of sprinkled with conspiracy theories
they're being spread to tens of
thousands of not millions of people on
social media it's to sow confusion and
to foment fear and cement hatred really
one example is you know the Chinese
eating habits that have been blamed for
the outbreak the Chinese as you may know
in some parts of the country in
particular are known to eat wild animals
and so when it was reported that the
virus may have come from bats videos
like these started circulating they
falsely claimed that the outbreak
started because people in Wuhan eat bat
soup now there are several things wrong
with this bat soup is not a thing Ilhan
these videos are in fact from the
Pacific island nation of Palau where bat
suit was considered a delicacy Chinese
scientists believe that the virus came
from bats but they made no connection to
to soup this particular kind of soup and
what may be most troubling is really
that what these videos are doing is
they're perpetuating this racist
stereotype that's especially in the
Western world still pretty widespread
that because they different things or
somehow dirty and so if they carry this
virus it's basically their own fault and
what are other examples are there well
one example is or one claim is just that
things are much worse we see these also
quite often so really blowing up the
numbers hundreds of thousands dead
millions infected obviously we know at
least right now it's not true one claim
in particular that's picked up steam has
been fueled by the popular YouTube
conspiracy theorist jordan saylor in a
tweet that he posted last week he called
a Corona Myers that quote fat disease
and then went on to note that a patent
had been filed in 2015 for the corona
Byers it is true that a patent was filed
in 2015 but it was for a different
strain of corona virus and it wasn't it
was you know filed to tried to develop
a vaccine to to combat this avian
coronavirus that's not what we're
looking at here presumably also it's
important to remember the corona virus
is not one disease it's a family of
viruses including SARS
so despite these claims being patently
false we're seeing them spread by tens
of thousands particularly the so called
anti-vaxxers so people who believe that
vaccines are somehow bad for your health
they're picking up on this on this
conspiracy theory to say well it's the
government that's behind it
they created the virus to basically as a
plot to force people to get vaccinated
it's part of a broader pattern that is
to sow mistrust in government the very
government not a lot of people right now
if we lie on to for news and for
information about how to deal with this
situation
often these the false claims are
surprisingly successful what can people
do to protect themselves against
misinformation like this
well one basically just don't trust
everything you see online that is true
always not just in this situation
several health ministries we're seeing
have really stepped up and are being
very active in debunking these false
information so Australia Malaysia
Singapore the US tech giant's Facebook
Twitter YouTube are trying to kind of
stem the flow of false news they're
trying to guide users to more reliable
sources of information at the end of the
day though I think this really
emphasizes again that the a lot of you
know of this false information is still
making it through and so these social
media platforms and many rely on for
news they can really situation like that
help make a health scare even scarier
Peter Rolla doll thank you thank you so
much